[Music]
foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show where we help people win in
their life specifically with their money
their work and their relationships the
phone number to jump in is triple eight
eight two five five two two five AAA
825-5225 I'm Ken Coleman I'm joined by
my colleague George Campbell they call
us Ramsey personalities that has nothing
to do with our multiple personality
disorders it's just it's also assuming
we have a lot of Personality yeah you
may not think we have any personality at
all George and I tend to think that
we're quite uh quite funny and pithy
we're better than watching paint dry
that's fair that's fair we've been known
to be called the root beer float of the
Ramsey Show when you have the obviously
we have two of us hosting every day any
combination and uh it's started to stick
a little bit and so that means we have
fun I will tell you this Joe George and
I are gonna have fun we enjoy being
around each other nothing else uh we're
gonna have fun with you we're not gonna
yell at you scream at you we'll poke a
little fun George is here to take your
money questions he answers the questions
honestly sometimes better than Dave I'll
just be honest I just said it wow yeah
easy to say when the big guy's not here
yeah it's exactly right he's not here
he's probably on the Golf Course uh but
you're much nicer is all I'm saying
there and then I'm here I'm the work guy
uh I hate the word expert but I hope you
with work issues because your income is
your greatest wealth building tool so
how many of you want to make more money
how many of you want to do it in a place
where you're invalued and so I'm the guy
to help you with that we work together
on these calls so we'll take your work
calls income related calls money calls
uh relationship calls shirt George and I
are both been married George is about to
be a dad so now he's already ready to
give you're going on are you hit 25
years 25 years Stacy and I celebrated 25
years that's incredible yeah it's very
exciting very exciting congratulations
uh Stacy has no judgment and tremendous
patience that's what that means there
you go all right we've got uh let's get
to the call shall we Danielle is joining
us now in Syracuse New York Danielle how
can we help
are you just I'm interested on your
guys's thoughts of you know Investments
while you're young when you have the uh
extra cash to hope to have some more you
know passive income in the future and
kind of just interested if I'm making
the right uh route nice tell us about
this extra cash give us a snapshot
suspender so I always spend less than
what I have but I I mean I have the
debts of you know a mortgage not an
investment property mortgage but really
strong full-time job and my husband
and trying to figure out you know we've
purchased an additional or in the
processing purchasing our second
additional home and we've got you know
some long-term renters but I'm you know
just for the way the market is these
days I'm wondering if it's
either rates are high so people are you
know maybe less apt to purchase a house
and more at to pay the rent but am I
signing myself up for too much debt that
I can't
handle in you know 15 years or is it
gonna you know the extra six grand you
get a year is that really worth it
well you're thinking through this the
right way and you've got a lot of wisdom
coming at this what's your household
income
uh about 180. fantastic okay and then
how much debt do you guys have
so
this is like including all the mortgages
correct yes
okay let's take a look here so probably
around uh 25 in student loans a thousand
um 120 in one of the houses and it'll be
140 in the other house
and then
and one car
okay so far you know this idea of
passive income sounds great it's just
like oh man I'm getting this cash flow
every month I don't have to work if I
don't want to but right now I feel
stressed looking down at these numbers
going man what a what if we could have
some peace in our life or we didn't owe
anyone anything
that's some serious cash flow anything
we do own that is producing cash is 100
other than our expenses and that's where
I want to get you guys to and what we
lay out is called the baby steps we tell
you to pay off the Consumer Debt first
then attack the mortgages
so making 180k if you just focused on
just the Consumer Debt the smallest at
first you could knock that out really
quickly couldn't you
yep so within a few months you could
knock out the student loans knock out
the car payment and then just have these
mortgages to worry about right
can I ask a question sure
when you look at like the interest rate
of the student loans because we've
refinanced then you look at the interest
rate of the car those are lower than
what I'm paying for my house
okay should I so should I put them
that's where like I have the struggle
like do I put the loans where I'm I'm
accruing more interest because we make
off you know we make probably three
principal payments a year on every house
try to pay it down but how you know you
say consumer first but what about the
interest we regardless of the interest
rate we found that it's more about
Behavior than knowledge when it comes to
personal finance 80 Behavior 20 head
knowledge and right now you're staring
at this big pile of debt you're trying
to invest you're trying to do 17 things
at once and you're not going to make
progress but when you focus on that
small debt it gets knocked out quick
when you ignore the interest rate
because this isn't about math
this is about actually gaining the
traction feeling the momentum and
sticking with it
and so you're right on on paper You're
Gonna Go wow I don't understand it and I
could make more in the market so I even
pay this down but when it comes to life
we don't think in numbers we think in
feelings and you sleep better at night
when you don't owe anyone anything so I
would if I'm in your shoes just slow
down
we'll get to real estate investing but
right now we're not going to buy any
more property we're going to focus on
the Consumer Debt let's focus on paying
down the mortgages we do have and then
for the future properties I would be
paying cash that sounds insane because
you're going that could be 10 years from
now yes and for those 10 years you're
going to be sleeping real good with no
payments in your life
so that's that's the route uh Ken I
don't know if you have any other
thoughts on this idea of passive income
and it sounds like you may not love what
you do for work right now I don't know
there's a yeah there could be a lot
going on there I think I think just what
you said is very helpful and I'm always
thinking of new listeners and viewers
that are coming in and they're hearing
this and I love what you said because if
you make this about the numbers well
this interest rate is lower here and
what happens is you get caught in this
strategy
and you go wait a second I've gotta I've
gotta pay over here to here here and
there's no momentum
if we understand the baby steps the way
that Dave set them up after years of
counseling people it's the momentum
piece and so that's why we don't say
well pay the one with the highest
interest rate it's about the behavior as
you said but really what comes as a
result of the baby steps for new people
I want you to understand it's momentum
and then momentum leads to lifestyle
change you know what I mean yeah I I
think people need to understand that
well because it's like this is about
you could go different ways and number
strategies that's why we have people
call them and try to argue with all the
time we're not like it's about momentum
and we're saying no debt at all so that
you have true peace so when you look at
it that way it does change your
perspective so get out of the numbers
one thing at a time a focused intensity
causes that momentum first then get an
emergency fund then start investing
that's right you can do all these things
but trying to do them all at once is
planning to fail that's right and you
and again that's a great Point you're
not getting as much momentum singular
focus of each baby step leads to the
best momentum as a result of the most
results momentum is an attitude it's a
spirit it's like okay I'm making
progress I want to keep going and I
develop a muscle for it so there is a
method to our Madness folks and a lot of
people think we're crazy mad and maybe
we are but we have a whole lot more
money and a whole lot more peace than
you do so there this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
oh
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace hallow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
foreign welcome back to the Ramsey Show
I'm Ken Coleman I'm joined by my
colleague George camel and we are here
for you this hour triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the phone
number eight eight two five five two two
five taking your work questions and your
money questions and you know whatever
else you want to ask today you know
we'll see how it goes triple eight eight
two five five two two five let's go to
Toronto Canada oh Adam what you're
excited about that I get excited about
the Canadian callers it's always it's
always a gamble oh hey okay let's see
what happens here Adam how can we help
uh hi can you guys hear me we can hear
you well sir
um I'm actually going to go to get
through today but I'm glad uh I have a
bit of a
Salama I'm trying to get uh solved um so
basically the situation here is uh I'm
trying to get married in December right
and I want to see if to get married but
I also have 48 000 worth of that so I
was thinking I don't know if I should
put getting married on pause and focus
on clearness that first or if I should
just keep seeing to get married and then
deal with it after I I don't know I'm
kind of new to listening to you guys so
I don't know what advice you would give
in that situation I know you guys to you
know get that tunnel vision and focus on
paying off that but I got it yeah do you
actually think that putting your wedding
on pause is possible what's the other
person think about that option have you
cleared that
I mean I mean she's she's okay with her
she's okay with it you know we're not
trying to do anything too big okay um so
yeah how much is the wedding gonna cost
uh we're planning to keep this small so
it shouldn't be too much but like I want
to save a certain amount because I'm
thinking about like you know not just
the wedding cost but uh getting a
apartment Furnishing place all these
other expenses that I'm thinking about
so what's the number
uh the number that I have in mind is
maybe like
everything
total 40K
just for the wedding
not just for the wedding like 10 to get
married and then getting us please well
rent is going to be an expense do you
not have rent right now
uh as of right now I live at home so my
expenses are very low that's another
thing to um are you working full-time
okay yeah I'm working full-time I just
started working full-time as a truck
driver clearly making like about 84k a
year awesome uh so my expenses are
roughly aren't too crazy
um so I'm able to see now that's a
that's another thing too because I know
once I get married my expenses are gonna
go up so I don't know if I should just
while I don't have too much expenses
Focus something like that hold on a
second Adam how much is she is she gonna
work and how much will she make or how
much does she make now
um as of right now she's not working
she's finishing up nursing school so
it'll just be my income how long before
she's out of nursing school
uh about a year okay okay so you will be
the uh the sole income provider for a
period of time even after you get
married
yes okay
if I'm in your shoes I'm not going to
put life on hold I'm going to get
married I'm going to do a wedding on a
budget that I can afford and that might
mean we do a twenty thousand dollar
wedding and we have family pitch in and
her family pitch in have you talked
about who's paying for this
um I mean as of right now I kind of
put it in my head that I'd be paying for
everything
how come you know I kind of want to
prepare financially that if it is just
me that I'm ready if I do get help that
would be great but I kind of wanted to
well let's have the conversation let's
get the families involved and say hey we
want to have this wedding here's our
budget are you guys able to contribute
would you want to contribute there's no
pressure
taking it on yourself is the move here
yeah Adam what's down America it is a
tradition it's certainly at least a
first expectation correctly if I'm wrong
George it's been a long time since I got
married but that the uh the the the
wives family fits the bill for that is
that the same in Canada Adam
uh I mean the thing is I'm like I'm from
Africa you know so it's kind of a lot of
culture cultural thing is kind of demand
and the Man's family takes care of
things you know well have you talked to
your parents about this
yeah the thing is I'm coming from a like
low-income single moment okay that's
fine so they can't contribute I would
still have a conversation with her
family because if this is on you then
I'm gonna do a Bare Bones what maybe we
do a courthouse situation do a big party
later George I don't like the twenty
thousand dollar suggestion no I'm just
trying to go we need to find a
compromise here we can't spend 40 Grand
on a wedding if this okay no no I don't
I don't plan to I don't plan to all
right now I listen I'm going to throw
this in here foreign
is going to happen because of an
apartment I mean an apartment you need
first month's deposit last month's
deposit maybe some moving cars that's
burnishing we don't need to go crazy
with Furniture right now yeah
if it's me I'm a little bit more
uh I don't know if it's old is old
school you can say it okay so if if the
fiance is willing to postpone the
wedding I'm not saying that you put life
on hold I understand the advice Georgie
so I don't disagree with you George but
my take is uh I would be willing to push
the wedding a little bit
uh to save money and I'd also be very
willing to do a low-key wedding if she
is
uh I just think that wedding prices have
gotten out of control and and I don't
mean to sound like the old fuddy-duddy
but I'm gonna go with it okay well it's
become more about it's a cultural
pressure to become more of our
reputation yeah it's like yeah I gotta
have a nice car so I'm gonna drag around
a 750 car payment I gotta be look
successful so I'm gonna go to school
that I can't afford and get a degree I
can't use I don't know when we just
don't at some point go this is nonsense
and just as a dude I'm going to put it
out there I remember we had a nice
little wedding it was lovely it wasn't
ridiculous but I remember like how
stressed out my wife was and I remember
the actual wedding day George
and the ceremony was about 20 minutes
long and you get done and you walk down
the aisle and everybody's smiling at you
and there's this moment where you're at
the back of the church it's just you
like The Wedding Planner hasn't even
caught up to you and I remember going
huh that was that was like a whole bunch
of hullabaloo a lot of fanfare a lot of
fanfare we could have just done a
private ceremony I get it it's about the
family but when we're trying to get
financially in a place of of Health I
don't know George I'd push the wedding a
little bit I'd scale way back that's me
yeah I mean you make 84 Grand you live
at home I'm gonna throw a few grand I'm
gonna live on nothing and throw a few
grand in a savings account every single
month and less cash flow or a small
thing if that's what you guys want to do
have the conversation with the bigger
family see who's able to contribute do
the wedding based on that budget and
then attack the debt as soon as you're
married
okay
but you got to have a conversation Adam
all this opinion you got to have a
conversation with your fiance the
families you've talked more about this
wedding with us than you have with the
families I think that's true that's a
problem we're just two random dudes yeah
you're right you're right I guess we
have to sit down with them but don't
take this on yourself as this burden of
like well I'm the man so I gotta take
this on listen they're gonna have uh
opinions about who makes the invite list
and therefore they need to have some
skin in the game too I appreciate the
African culture all the culture I
appreciate all of that but man
if the Canadian if the Canadian in-laws
would like to punch in some money I
would take it pal I would take it you
know wouldn't you absolutely hey it's a
big expense yeah just so you know that
that is kind of like because I've kind
of been listening to us for a couple
months now and now that I'm really
taking in how much that I already have
40 000 it's really like what kind of
debt is it no I really
um I have a list here you want me to go
through it how am I like yeah just very
quick categories
okay okay so 25 000 of it is a car note
okay uh I'd say
uh five thousand is One credit card
another five thousand is the
um
Best Buy loan 4 000 of it is student
loans
3 000 of it is my truck school loan
uh 2500 is another credit card
uh a thousand dollars is uh like a
personal someone that gave me a loan
another thousand is uh credit card man I
would if I'm in your shoes personally I
might just sell the car if you want to
pay for this wedding and be done with it
and get something cheaper
the control for your income so if you
want to pay it off aggressively and keep
it that's fine but with where you're at
and you're feeling the pinch right now
you can always get a nice car later
so that would be the other option you
have on the table to at least clear some
of this debt fast if I'd do a picnic
style wedding with Solo cups that's what
I would do you don't have to invite Ken
yeah oh yeah I'm not coming anyway
tomorrow in December that's going to be
a Brisk one
[Music]
anybody I just women love them he's done
with them I'm done that's it I don't
want to do it hey don't move he's George
Campbell I'm Ken Coleman this is the
Ramsay show we'll be right back
[Music]
thank you
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
tomorrow
welcome back America you have joined the
conversation about your life your money
your work your relationships here on the
Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman joined by
George camel the phone number to jump in
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five triple eight eight two five
five two two five time for our question
of the day brought to you by neighborly
your hub for Home Services if you're
moving you have a long list of to-do's
but neighborly has local Pros like house
Master five star painting and Junk King
to check items off that list visit
neighborly.com today to schedule Home
Service Experts near you today's
question comes from Julia in New Mexico
I've been hearing reports of the dollar
potentially losing value which would
affect 401K Investments Etc hearing
recommendations on diversifying into
gold and silver I've heard in the past
you do not recommend this based on past
performance of the metals do you still
recommend the 401K and stock market
Investments over the physical gold in
this current economy let's say you
George
yes short answer longer answer yes I'll
add some flavor to it and Ken can chime
in I actually did a video about this on
my YouTube channel oh you did and like
the I didn't know this existed there's
like gold trolls out there they love to
jump in the comments of these videos and
be like it's all coming down because
they know weak-minded folks like you
will read them that's right don't jump
in the comments
I didn't respond to them I just say I
saw them yeah but see that's garbage in
you see what I mean garbage out every
people are not healthy everybody
deserves to be seen known and left I
disagree regardless I disagree they're
trolling yeah but yeah the thing with
gold is you can look at the past
performance and I compare it to that of
the stock market and the returns are not
great kind of abysmal you would have
been way better off investing in mutual
funds in the stock market over a long
period of time now what this is actually
getting at is the fear and paranoia that
hey if it all comes crashing down gold
will be our last
you know symbol of hope I got news for
you if it comes crashing down you're not
going to want to trade my goals you're
not walking around talking about how
much gold you have haven't you seen one
of those bad western movies I've seen I
am Legend right you're gonna be going
hey does anyone have food water bullets
yeah fuel yeah exactly ammo that's the
kind of stuff trademark fan so the idea
that every single company in America is
going to go bankrupt because that's what
you're saying if you're saying the stock
market's going to go to zero I'm going
to lose it all or the dollar is going to
get so far devalued that my retirement
account will be worth nothing then you
need to turn off the news
that's true and get yourself a bunker
yes that's where these people are
heading and I don't think it's healthy I
don't think it's realistic and
truthfully if the whole thing's come
crashing down just take me let the good
Lord just take me when I'm I don't want
to survive in this post-apocalyptic I'm
with you I'm going to the beach so I'm
gonna build myself a shanty and uh you
know I'll join you there live off the
land yeah uh you know so and we found
also that actual wealthy people they
don't hoard gold they may have a little
bit of precious metals but I mean
they're only gold they have is on their
wrist Dave's wearing his watch maybe a
gold chain yeah he's a chain guy he's a
chain guy yeah I don't think people
realize that yeah he likes the gold
chain it's always there I've seen it so
yeah I would I would avoid this the
other problem with gold is resale as
well if you buy the gold for a certain
price you're not gonna be able to
necessarily sell it for that or more oh
soon after so I'm sticking to mutual
funds in companies that you know have a
good track record that will grow I like
it versus a fear-based investment like
gold I love it good stuff let's go to
Savannah now who joins us in Phoenix
Arizona Savannah how can we help
hello yes
um my husband and I don't have any debt
we have 17 000 in cash and we are at the
at the beginning of step three however
we need a truck
um I'm just wondering if why do you need
a truck
yes a truck why
why a truck I'm just curious
for my husband's um business okay
um we need so I'm wondering how do we
know how much we can afford for the
truck do we spend all the 17K on the
truck and then start with step three
Afters
what kind of truck are we talking about
because trucks are really expensive and
they hold their value they're overpriced
in my opinion right now so what are you
talking about
well ideally we want to just we would
want to find a truck and just pay it all
in cash my husband has other plans he
wants the Ford F-150
um and the prices you're looking at it
in the 30s what kind of business does he
have
it's taxidermy
okay why does he need it F-150 with all
the bells and whistles for taxidermy
right he doesn't he just needs a truck
with a with a bed exactly there's a lot
of thirty thousand dollars I mean I I
listen I could get on right now on this
little computer here and find you trucks
that'll get him from A to B and you can
throw some dead animals in there or
whatever it is that he does the idea of
just hauling dead animals and then
getting a really nice vehicle to do that
in is kind of hilarious to me right
agreed you guys are out of debt I wish
he was on the phone with us right now
because you guys are out of debt you're
the beginning of baby step three you're
so close that you don't want to just go
blow it on a really fancy schmancy truck
that he quite frankly doesn't need but
if he puts it off and he gets a basic
truck let's say something in the ten
twelve thousand dollar range
uh by the way I just bought a fabulous
George a fabulous Ford Explorer for my
son oh nice uh and it's 90 000 miles on
it
12 Grand fantastic condition bought it
from a lady that's in her late 60s it
can be done folks it can be done he he
could get an SUV here's the point he can
get the nice truck later you guys are so
close don't go backwards right now by
using all this cash on that truck am I
right George yeah this money needs to be
earmarked for your emergency fund and
then we'll begin saving up for this
truck
so how soon does he need this truck
they use it by September 1st what
happens on September 1st
that's when um
I'll start picking up
all the dead animals all right I got a
question this is fascinating I have ADHD
so full confession everybody why can't
they drop the animals off to him they're
the ones I mean I listen my dad had two
deer heads hanging in our house you know
uh when I was a kid and I think he took
the deer to the taxidermist why does he
have to go pick him up
right
um so
his business is based up in the White
Mountains kind of close to Show Low
Arizona and we're living near Phoenix
um so it's the it's the traveling time
to bring to pick up the mouth where he
has them dropped off at and then bring
them down
okay okay well I'll give you the
parameters because I actually want to
answer your question after we were asked
you for the truck so when it comes to
buying a depreciating asset a car you
want to make sure that everything with
motors and wheels in it in your life is
no more than half of your annual income
so what is your annual income
however I'm just on
okay and then with his business I would
say
um he just started this business last
fall so and I was thinking I think he's
making 15K with that and then he'll
he'll pick up and sell insurance at you
know in the winter time and his base pay
will be 15 an hour
okay so that's about 30k a year there
but he's only doing it part time I
wonder if he needs to work full time and
do this on the side for now until he
gets this thing kicked up because right
now it's going to be tough times for you
guys on top of trying to save up to buy
this truck but I will tell you uh based
on what you just told me I'd get the
cheapest truck possible and I'm looking
online right now uh actual reality and
you can get you know early 2000 for Ford
F-150s for six grand eight grand
even a 2010 for nine grand that would be
the ballpark you're looking at here
for a work truck to haul dead animal so
if he's getting all Starry Eyed because
he went to the dealership he needs to
slowly back away and keep his wallet
tight where I can see it
oh I like that George because he's about
to make a real dumb decision buying a
shiny brand new truck when he has a
startup business that it may not even
make enough to feed his family while
you're on maternity leave
so do not use the emergency fund for
this it is not an emergency I don't care
what he says scrounge up the eight or
nine grand and get a used Ford F-150 or
whatever truck but please please don't
don't upgrade until he's got this
business running and moving and you guys
are making really good money
really good stuff I love this just
pulling up the used trucks for sale
reality helps because people go again
you can't find trucks under 28 grand yes
it's not the truck you want and guess
what trucks still run 20 years later
it's amazing how that works there's a
Toyota Tundra 182 000 miles you know how
long that'll run it'll run for 700 000
miles I'm told it will Outlast me you
know you and I we'd never look good
driving a truck I take offense to that
dude yeah I don't get a tundra I don't
know we'll see America needs to see it
all right more of your calls
Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman
George Campbell joins me this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number if you want to jump
in on the conversation we'll take your
questions about money your work
situation which affects your money
relationships that affect money and
Beyond
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Adrian's up next and am I reading
this right Latina Romania I don't know
if I said that right but we'll see
Adrian how can we help
yep yeah that was about right
um I have um I'm 24.
um and my wife we both graduated
University and I've been working at the
same time for about six or seven years
as a user interface designer I'm making
around forty thousand dollars a year
currently living in Romania born and
raised
um
um we're building our house cash only we
don't have any debt uh we're doing that
just from where I'm working because my
wife is babysitting at the moment she we
have a one-year-old
um and I was just wondering how can I
um you know keep up with working uh
providing for my family and keeping my
dream alive which my dream is to do as
much
music as I can because I'm a musician at
core I've been raised with music and I
love and enjoying music in general are
you a uh are you a musician only or do
you sing as well so are you playing an
instrument what is it yeah I'm playing
the piano I'm singing and I'm also
composing wow and so let's let's let out
the whole dream 15 20 30 years from now
if you could snap your fingers and make
it so what would that look like
um I would really love to to have as
much
a meaningful music as possible uh
into the world so people can enjoy it
and can take comfort in it so you've got
albums out yeah walk us are you do you
want to be an artist you want to be
touring do you want to compose for film
be a little more specific
yeah um actually the the dream is
um I I have a like a classical uh
background in music and I'm doing all
sorts of composition Walters and
classical music basically right
um have you and gotten anything out so
far have you put anything out whether it
be on your own website have you gotten
any contracts where you've written music
uh for organizations or or uh musical
theater or anything like that
yeah I've actually
um recorded a single that's called
yesterday and it's out on all uh
streaming platforms sure and how old are
you again
24 24. okay so the question is I got to
take care of my family
and I want to keep this dream alive and
and I love that I I actually have you
know I know what that's like when I
started in the broadcasting Adrian I was
33 three little ones
um running my own company a very small
business and I had the exact same
situation so you're gonna have to treat
your music like I treated my
broadcasting I was getting basic
experience getting knowledge
so I was taking some training courses I
took a few broadcasting classes on the
side I I was running my business and
working really hard
to make sure that I was using my time
wisely so that I had more time to go
again audition at times I had to
audition I was doing radio on Saturdays
you know and so you just a little bit at
a time but you never stop and so you the
main thing is the main thing taking care
of your family and you've got it you're
doing it I think I would guess even in
Romania with this technology job that
you have the opportunity to climb the
ladder financially is that true
yeah that's true I mean the top two
percents okay so you want to keep
climbing and keep taking care of the
family but keep producing music and I
would just challenge you to show your
work try to get yourself not just put
out your own music but can you sign up
you know can you get some clients where
maybe you're scoring some music for
local theaters you know National stuff
how can I get my work I just ran into an
old buddy George
uh by the name of Jim won't say his last
name and had seen him in years
and he has been scoring music for the
national Nashville Symphony he does a
lot of stuff all around the country
working from his home scoring music much
like Adrian does so Adrian I want you to
expand into trying to work more for
other people because that's doing two
things you are doing the thing that you
love
but you're getting paid for it and then
that allows you to stock stock stack up
money so that long term uh you're gonna
have a lot more freedom to actually put
more of your own stuff out that's what I
would tell you uh on the work side
George you want to add anything to that
Financial yeah well as a former musician
I mean I still am a musician but I was
kind of doing what you were doing I put
some albums out there I was doing live
gigs and it's still a love of mine it's
not something I wanted to pursue full
time but for you I would say with the
Advent of the internet on top of what
Ken said which is you know get connected
to people who are actually in the craft
getting paid to do it and go to the
places that's happening the orchestras
wherever that is but also with the
internet now you can jump on to some
amazing Forums on maybe there's a Reddit
Community a Twitter Community for this
start a tick tock account an Instagram
account and start uploading videos of
you playing and composing and breaking
it down for people show them behind the
scenes and you never know you start to
build an audience over there
and opportunities will start to happen
for you but you have to put yourself out
there even more you can't just upload a
song to Spotify and go well didn't
happen you got to continue and persist
for years and I wish you the best yeah
thank you for the great dream I love it
you've got it you're on your way Adrian
just don't quit
best advice I could ever give someone
who's got that kind of a dream let's go
to Josh now in Lafayette Louisiana Josh
how can we help
hey gentlemen it's uh it's good to be on
with you thank you for taking my call
you bet
uh so my current situation is I have as
my family has 30 000 in debt um student
loan and a van loan
as it stands right now I'm a maintenance
supervisor at a retirement facility and
I make 50 000 per year and I'm not
getting anywhere ahead
and I've been mulling over different
ideas of how to increase my income
you know it's just yes I mean I have
some thoughts but I was hoping to get
your guys's Insight on you know Avenues
I could consider taking how how handy
are you I'm guessing you're fairly handy
based on your job title
yes yeah if it were me and I were you
and I'm the least handy guy you've ever
met in your life okay I can barely use a
screwdriver or a hammer you know that's
dangerous but I would be looking for
handyman jobs odd jobs you know stuff
that you can do on the side keep your
main gig but because you know people
need stuff fixed all the time there's a
premium there man I just paid a sizable
amount of money Ken for a handyman that
was at my house for the last couple days
right and let me tell you Josh you could
double your income that's exactly right
because these handyman they're not
charging 20 an hour no they're charging
50. 60 even 90 dollars an hour
right to do basic things yeah I mean
Josh if you so that means you could find
another facility that may not be able to
pay you full time but maybe they pay you
half and you come and fix their stuff at
night and weekends and you live in a
neighborhood I assume right
yes I do if you've got a Facebook group
or you leave little hangers on the door
and you say hey I live in the
neighborhood I do handyman work yeah
here's my rate would love to help you do
one good job and the neighbors are all
telling you gotta hire Josh oh my gosh
she's the best he was professional he
showed up on time and you can charge
easily 50 60 bucks an hour
question on something else I've been
considering real quick we got about a
minute and a half
yes sure I was also thinking uh I am I
had considered getting an LLC and
opening up handyman work on the side I
had considered getting a real estate
license I figured that'd be a good way
to get some additional work Moonlighting
after work and then also maybe Market
myself as a as a handyman is that even a
practical thought
I think it's going to take a lot of time
and money and unless it's something
you're really passionate about I
wouldn't do it as easy money because
that is real estate is nothing but
getting started but if that's something
you really want to do long term then you
would want to make that transition but
I've talked to a lot of great Real
Estate Pros and coaches of Real Estate
Pros at some point you got to go all in
on that to that for that to work I like
you stacking cash
doing what you already do very very well
without having to pay for more schooling
and license yeah you're not paying
anything you're just counting your money
baby and getting ahead we're really
proud of you Josh you're on your way sir
hang up the phone start calling people
hey George Campbell good hour James
Childs our fearless leader thank you sir
and the team behind the glass thank you
America for listening this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
it's Ken if you love the show and want a
deeper dive on your money Journey we
have a Weekly Newsletter that gives you
trending and helpful articles and tips
on following the Ramsay win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show where we help you win in
your life specifically your money your
work and your relationships triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
phone number eight eight two five five
two two five I'm Ken Coleman joined by
the incomparable the inevitable uh
George cam the insufferable sufferable
some would say but I think he's pretty
fantastic and we have a lot of fun
together and we're here to help you
let's go Megan is up in the windy city
Chicago Illinois Megan how can we help
hi I have been with my current company
for just under seven years and was
recently approached by a leader within
my department to apply for a position
that they have with their team and so
I'm just looking for advice I love my
current team my leader the work that I
do I'm a little bit apprehensive to
apply for this new position however it
would come with a salary increase and my
family and I are in baby step two so I'm
just wondering do I listen to my gut my
husband both of which are usually
correct or do I seek out this
opportunity that would come with a
little bit of a pay bump in order to pay
down that debt Factor all right I want
to get the facts
and George and I'll weigh in on this but
based on what I hear
you should always trust your gut
and the husband agrees with the gut that
is two for two theirs but let's look at
this and because you also said a little
bit of a pay bump which tells me it's
the ROI on this of changing and
everything that goes with changing is
probably not worth it but but what are
you making now and what would you make
if you took this promotion
sure So currently I make 86 and I think
that I could get close to about 100K but
our household currently is at 148k
combined all right so we're talking
about fourteen thousand dollars before
taxes yes okay
um and our our current debt is 135k so
that changes it a little bit that's all
Consumer Debt
uh yes student loan a credit card two
vehicles yeah
what are your concerns about this
promotion in other words layout for us
the reasons as to why you're
apprehensive and you just didn't you
don't feel like it's a good fit
sure so the hiring manager I was
actually up against them for a different
promotion day one out uh they were the
better fit so this new position that I
would be applying for would be reporting
to them so they're a new leader
um and I'm just not sure how their
leadership style will be whereas my
current leader is incredible there's a
lot of flexibility autonomy um wonderful
work-life balance having small children
at home so
I guess it's just the fear of jumping
into the unknown when I have a sweet
deal right now
yeah but I also think you know enough
and I'm just curious the only thing I
want to know is do you know enough about
the position to compare it to what
you're currently doing and you can
clearly see forget the new leader and
and all the good things I have with my
current leader I just am better at this
other work that I'm in now I enjoy the
work now is that clear to you
it is I enjoy the work that I do now
more um
yeah this new role would just open up my
skill set a little bit okay so I want
George to step in here
um because he's the Money numbers guy
but you take 14 000 it looks really good
when you look at it that way but it's
not going to be fourteen thousand
dollars so you're talking about making a
change with all of the unknowns about
the leader
and all of the knowns about your current
leader your current flexibility you love
the current job
I it's not worth it because after tax
it's not gonna be that much
and you're you you and your husband
would be better off Selling Stuff making
side hustle money to to come up with
that extra 14. but let's just say you
were to step into this and take it go
against your gut what your husband knows
and you end up stepping into this and
you don't enjoy it think about how much
time
how much time you're spending in a roll
that's not a good fit for you from a
flexibility standpoint with the kiddos
to the to the relationship with the new
boss I mean it's not worth it it's not
that big of a payoff if it were a
hundred grand and I knew you could step
back into the old position a year later
maybe but this is an absolute
big Blinky neon no stay put George
yeah I'm with Ken and I'll I'll make the
caveat I'm looking at these numbers I'm
scared I mean 135 Grand is a whole lot
of debt comparatively to your income and
you have a great income are the cars
really nice or is this all student loans
it's predominantly student loans the
vehicles are fine but yeah I would say
it's student loans both of which are
mine okay if you're going to keep this
current role I would go get a second job
I'd be willing to sell one of the cars
maybe both and get something cheaper
because I want this debt gone in 18
months and if you can't do that then we
need to find out another way to make
that happen right now
because that means you're throwing in
two years that means you're throwing 70k
at this debt a year could you guys do
that currently with your budget
I think so yes
all right are you doing a monthly budget
right now because that's you're talking
throwing six grand a month at this debt
I think that we could if we went
scorched Earth now let me say this
because George has brought up a good
point
Megan instead of us talking about you
changing jobs how about we change cars
that's a whole lot less traumatic
do you have do you have some equity in
those cars
yes
Megan if it were me and George is right
this that number scares me I wouldn't be
able to sleep well I'd start selling
cars and that changes the timeline
and you still have flexibility great job
with the kiddos I I'm telling you I
would sell the cars
I really would wouldn't you George yeah
I mean depending on what the cars are
worth and what you could get for them
and you're downgrading but I think there
needs to be some some level of sacrifice
here and if it has to happen in the cars
let's do that but we need some Behavior
change because what got us into this was
some Behavior
credit cards getting nice cars we
couldn't afford all that it sounds like
you guys have you've made a change I
don't know what your why was what that
trigger point was for you but you're
ready to do something about it
but you're unwilling to take the
promotion so we need to find another
place to sacrifice because this would
have been great it would have added
another you know probably 900 bucks a
month to throw the debt so we need to
figure out a way to create that margin
if it's not going to be from a promotion
what are you thinking Maggie we've hit
you with a lot
you know what it's exactly what I needed
to hear you're just holding up a mirror
for me so thank you both all right
that's what we're here for you're
awesome I love your spirit if you guys
can do the car thing it's only short
term
and just think about the scorched Earth
that's part of scorched Earth strategy
right there you get out of this thing a
lot faster you guys are making really
good money and then we replace the cars
so you know Now's the Time to do this
when the kids are little you know what I
mean like this is the time to do that
they don't care what the car looks like
absolutely that's a great Point thank
you you bet so we did what we could we
held up the mirror and well here's
what's going on
so there's a lot of options here the
only option is we can't keep staying the
same so if we're going to turn down the
extra 14 Grand we've got to figure out
how we're going to get rid of 135 Grand
in debt well but I want to be very clear
well she's not turning down 14. that
would that's not real dollars and to
change your life in a potentially
negative way in the workplace you're
spending all that time there wasn't
enough Roi on that for me I want to make
sure people I didn't share she's not
turning down 14. that's the numbers guy
I have to have to put Pitch it that way
no but but you understand why from a
different perspective it's not worth it
she'd be better off getting a second job
I'm visible My Career can help that's it
I took a promotion I shouldn't have
taken yeah I don't want Life's too short
to be miserable not fun let's get after
it this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
backed by their 100 percent satisfaction
guarantee and shipping is always free
at blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings go
to blinds.com now and save 45 off
selected products visit blinds.com today
for more info
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by George Campbell
and we are coming to you from our
Nashville Tennessee area
base World Headquarters I bring this up
because we live George and I both live
in a suburb of Nashville called Franklin
Tennessee and uh boy everybody's talking
about this and James this is funny that
you bring this in there our fearless
producer brings us into us
this story he's so brave uh
did I say he was Brave he said Fearless
it's just a it's an empty compliment it
it's just what else am I going to say
you know what I mean I'm trying to I
didn't mean to derail you Ken I was just
adding some color commentary I love it
so James my wife tells me about this
last night and then you bring it in and
uh this is the headline here
uh in my hands Franklin Tennessee Kroger
converts to entirely self-checkout we
live in the future no grocery clerks is
that what you call them by the way do we
still call them clerks do you even know
what a clerk is I think it ages you to
say clerk uh there it is see there it is
you taking a shot at my age again well I
don't think the 16 year old at Publix is
like I'm a clerk that's why I asked the
question you don't have to be snippy
about it just a yes or no suffice clerk
went the way of the stewardess there we
go thank you James we're done with it oh
so we don't say Clerk and we don't say
stewardess apparently it makes me want
to say it all the more uh anyway a
Kroger in Middle Tennessee uh right here
in this area uh this is in the Cool
Springs area it's kind of the business
district of our town and uh so this is a
corporate Affairs manager for Kroger's
National division Lauren Bell she's
quoted as saying these allow our
customers to scan and bag their own
items it's a fast friendly experience
they're talking about it like it's a new
invention I've been doing this for years
before it was cool yeah the story is is
that that's all there is is the
self-checkout now do you or do you
self-checkout
if I have uh I'd say under 10 or 15
items I'll do it oh so there's a point
where you say yeah that's too much for
me or if I have like 19 different things
of Lacroix it's just a lot to carry I'd
rather have them come out and scan it
and make it easier on me okay or if it's
a lot to bag I'm not a big fan of
bagging and if there's a bagger at the
end I love that that's my they're my
favorite I like where you went there so
really it's about the bagger it's about
the bagging experience for me okay uh
for those of us who for those who are
not fond of the experience of
self-checkout staff will still be
available in the store for customers who
don't want to or unable to scan their
own so this is where I go why is this a
new story why are we talking about it
they said it was going to be all
automated all self-checkout but then if
you really don't like it we'll call
Barney from the back and he'll check you
out so you see I don't know what I will
say if I have this kind of stuff bothers
if I have fruits or vegetables I'm out I
don't want to be looking for a tiny
little code and going through their
little iPad on the screen trying to
figure it out yeah all right but they
say it's not going to happen at all
locations and the reason the tie into
this show yeah we talk a lot about
career and work and how technology is
changing things and people get spooked
going like Ken what does this mean for
my job yeah and they stated at the
bottom there that no no one is uh being
eliminated so no one's getting fired you
know why no one's getting eliminated
because of all the cranky people like
you that'll go I don't want to scan my
banana
I I want you to do it and so they're
gonna bring somebody from the back to
take care of your fruit thank you or if
you get you know wine or something like
that that requires ID Ken you've been
there I I get it I just wire I don't
understand like either go all
self-checkout and we lay people off and
give them a better job somewhere else I
don't understand I need to take it back
Ken because I just looked up Kroger jobs
they're called grocery Clerks
grocery bagger general merchandise clerk
so clerk is still here what would you
want to be called a bagger or a clerk
yeah uh see I make the point he makes a
fair point all right so will AI in all
seriousness will AI re eliminate and
reduce the need for a certain amount of
humans no question but remember this if
you look back over the last 50 years you
sat there and thought for a second
technology and how it's coming to the
world it's always spit off new jobs so
if you are in certain types of positions
clerical roles administrative roles
gathering information
those kind of jobs will be eliminated
because AI can take care of that but you
take this right here this very story to
me is a bit absurd and it points out the
absurdity of fear over AI
they've got self-checkout they say the
whole store self-checkout but if you
really don't want to do it we're going
to get somebody else to come out like an
Apple store in there everyone's just
hanging out waiting for something to go
wrong well I did it the other day and uh
we had a problem with one of my coffee
creamers it wouldn't scan WOW and uh I
would normally get frustrated with that
and I look over nice young man Zips over
a couple things on the screen
I'm a nuisance you know I'm at Costco or
something the red light goes off I see
it didn't weigh it properly
so neurotic to me I don't care it's
exhausting so I try to do self-checkout
when I don't want to deal with people
but Trader Joe's for example don't
doesn't have self-checkout it's all
people and they're the nicest people
you could ask for I uh now see this is a
very good point if you gave me the
option to do self checkout or I get
someone to take care of me every time
I'm going to take the human touch
there's no question about it you love
people some people want to avoid people
yeah I like being taken care of so do
you
that's your issue you like being
pampered well Canada's looking for the
compliment from the cashier I am
but they always got one especially if
there's a tip involved I'm not tipping
the cashier clerk but if you're at the
ice cream shop and they go oh I like
your uh like your shirt you a big golfer
all of a sudden Kenny boys hitting that
20 not true my response is yes I uh you
know I attempt to play I'm not very good
but I enjoy the clothing thank you very
much what do I owe you I'm not tipping
the ice cream or the coffee people I'm
not doing it George well now
self-checkout is asking for a tip so
that's where I draw the line what do you
mean self-checkout is asking for a tip
self-checkout screens are now now
starting to ask for tips who am I
tipping myself yes
great job Ken we're going to give this
money to someone who actually needs uh
the tip thing's gone out it's out of
control folks Americans need to unite
the people in the lobby are shaking
their hands it's time for Americans to
unite arm and arm and stop tipping
anybody other than a waiter or waitress
can we say that call in for Congress or
the delivery person sorry we're gonna
get hate mail over that one gotta get
the delivery people in there who else am
I missing George that covers who is it
okay to tip that's it
yeah hi Barber
service based work I do have to tip the
barber but that's because I get a
shampoo and a condition plus the cut oh
we're off the rails I know all right
let's go to Stephanie in Austin Texas
Stephanie how can we help
not self-checkout oh say that again you
got an opinion on this well you you
broke up yeah I'm team not self-checkout
I want someone to check me out every
time all right Stephanie thank you that
is your right is American and I
appreciate you voicing it how can we
help today
so I am calling because we
got into the baby steps and we're pretty
far along a little backwards but we're
here and the only debt that we have left
is on our primary residence and an
investment property that we have so it's
substantial but it is our you know house
and our uh renter property and we feel a
little Frozen as to where we should
focus our dollars now that we're kind of
moving into this world
um and so I'm just hoping you can
enlighten me a little bit
um with what we have and our income do
we pour it all into knocking out the
investment property which we might be
selling by the way so it might take care
of itself or do we pour it all into
paying down our primary dwelling what's
on the primary what's on the investment
um 613k is what is owed on the primary
and the investment property is 84k
um that's owed please tell me you have
an amazing income
I I don't I don't know what translates
to amazing but it's 200k a year myself
alone okay my husband's probably 150k
yeah that's what I was hoping for I was
like that is a big fat mortgage and uh
you guys have an amazing income okay so
I would we're up against the clock I
would pay off the investment property
first set a goal for that then start
attacking primary and just set a goal I
want it done in less than 15 years I
think you guys could do it and probably
closer to five to ten get all this
knocked out so it doesn't need to be
every single extra dollar but set an
aggressive goal and then try to beat
that goal and still live your life while
you're at it we move from intense to
intentional in baby steps four and on
and you guys are there you're crushing
it and she said they may sell that
investment property and so if they
decide to do that throw it on them you
got a four savings plan at that point so
I'd still knock it out fantastic all
right well done thank you Stephanie for
the call all right George and I'm gonna
take a break we'll continue to argue in
the commercial about self-checkout
versus the clerk we'll see what we come
up with don't move this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by George camel we are
here for you this hour the phone number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five taking your money calls your
calls related to your work
and otherwise in other words your income
I'm here to help you with that as well
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go to Connor now who joins us
in Dallas Texas Connor how can we help
hey Ken how are you doing I'm doing well
sir what's going on oh nothing I uh I
just had a quick question for you okay
I'm kind of at a point in my career
where I have a few doors that are open
to me
um I work for a really good company now
because of that they are big about
developing their people and I'm just
kind of wondering how you know which
road to pick when you have a few
different options and I feel like I have
skills that could help me go down any of
the roads okay I love this question all
right so I'll reframe this
so when someone has multiple
professional opportunities how do we
weigh those and make the choice that's
what you're asking yeah so the first
thing I'm going to look at is
um long term
okay I'm always going to look at long
term first because most people make
professional decisions based on the
short term
in other words they look at well I'm
going to get a pay bump of X percent or
certain amount of money
and I'm going to get a nice title
and that feels really good I'm wanted
I'm valued and so we we think oh well
that's a no-brainer
and we will step into positions
many times that aren't a good fit for us
in the short term
and even worse don't position us for the
long term okay so that's why I like to
look at the long term so let's say
you've got let's just be uh let's be
very very realistic in your situation
how many opportunities do you have in
front of you potential jobs at this
company so if you've got three so I'm
going to look at the three and I'm gonna
go okay
which one of these three
best positions me for the long term or
where I want to be long term makes sense
is that clear to you which one let's
call it one let's call them uh a b and c
which one
um is is the best long-term positioning
for you to get where you want to go
like you want the actual position no
just just tell me of the three column A
B and say let's call this one a a is so
so so which one is it describe that to
me position a is the one that is is the
best long term what is that
um I I think that is going to be more of
a finance related role and uh I think it
does position me best to use the
education I have now and the skills that
I have okay but what do you want to do
long term in the finals I'd like to get
into more of a managerial role down the
road I have some good mentors now right
and uh I think that is probably the area
where I would best get that chance the
other side is more of a uh it's a good
it's a better job for now but I don't
think there is really a uh a leadership
role down that Corridor okay that's a
perfect example of what I'm looking for
I want to look at long term
and then I'm going to look at is this of
the best fit for me
and in in the short term meaning you
know I can get in here and I know I can
at least do the job I may not love it
but I've got enough talent to do it and
it's positioning for the long term it
feels like you know the one is that
correct is there a clear winner
there is quite a
part of the two meaning
going backwards no
um both of them if I went down option A
I would make slightly more than I make
now but option b even though I think the
long term where I want to go might be a
little different I think the earnings
opportunity is considerably
um how much better
um like 40 better 35 40 percent better
okay how long do you see yourself if we
took both positions how long before you
would think that you'd have a chance to
move up and because at some point if we
take the one with more money now you
would have to sounds like pivot or move
left or right not just keep going up is
that is that correct yeah I think so how
long what would be the length of time in
the position it pays more
and oh well in the position I think I
could do that job for for four to five
years before
um I would kind of age out of that and
they would want me to go a different
direction what about the other one that
is it less of a pay bump but it's the
better long-term positioning how long
would you stay in that before you felt
like you would be moving to the next
wrong I think that would be like two to
three years because that department is
smaller and I think the opportunity for
growth there will be larger and with the
money catch up after that if you move on
in two or three years I think even if I
moved up in that role it would get me
closer to that job but still not the
same so I guess it's just a priority
thing huh well you're talking to a guy
who named a book from paycheck to
purpose because I've just talked to too
many people that'll take a job for a
paycheck and it wears off okay George
you know this There's Something About Us
humans it doesn't take us long to adapt
to more money and once the high of the
money wears off now you're stuck with do
I enjoy this is this something I want to
do long term and that's my concern Conor
is that you take the 40 bump
but it doesn't put you in position to
get where you ultimately want to go and
you'll you'll end up regretting and
resenting that position
okay is this the company Long Term
because you're telling me the kind of
role you want to be in leadership but do
we know for sure hey I'd be here forever
yeah yeah it's the opportunity was that
I have really good bosses I have really
good people around me and it's the
industry I want to be in okay yeah
how much do you want that leadership
position how much
I I you know I've never been in it so
I'm not sure at this point I just feel
like it's the natural step right and
like when you're progressing in your
career dig into that though
go hang out with some leaders that are
in that type of management role in this
company have lunch with them coffee and
find out you think you want it you don't
know that you want it and George that
concerns me and and Connor go find out
you can hang out with leaders in those
type of positions enough to get an idea
what I really enjoy doing that all day
long
that's that's a key you got to make sure
you check that out sometimes we think it
would be a natural progression and a
natural progression doesn't mean that
it's the right person especially younger
in your career you look at the leaders
you go man they make great money look at
them I want to be like them when I grow
up and then you realize man they're in
meetings all day and they're dealing
with people issues and unless you love
that stuff don't step into it just for
the bigger paycheck it's true it wears
off quickly folks let's go to JC in
Cedar Rapids Iowa how can we help
hi hi my question for you today is how
can I be successful in budgeting and
that ultimately leading success and
paying down debts and saving for a house
when our income is
um
sporadic
um how sporadic are we talking amount
um my husband can get paid
um large sums of money
um
like once a week or every two months
are there ever are there months with
zero dollars
um the month last February the most we
had the entire month was twelve hundred
dollars
okay and are you bringing in income as
well
no okay so if it's all on him we've
gotta and where are you at in the baby
steps
um probably the beginning
um because we started paying down debts
and saving money and then we got to a
few months where we didn't have enough
income to cover the bills and
I'll give you the short answer now I'm
gonna gift you one year of every dollar
premium and inside of that there's a
paycheck planning tool which will help
you with a regular income which is
awesome but the key here is you create a
prioritized spending plan if you have a
regular income which means we're going
to budget based off the lowest estimate
so if we get a thousand bucks this month
where is it going to go we need food
shelter utilities transportation that is
your A1 if there's extra money beyond
that we're going to apply it towards our
other goals our debts a subscription
whatever those things may be and so that
will help you to create that priority
list and then pay the first one and then
whatever whenever the money runs out
that's when it runs out and you may want
to set aside money when a big lump sum
comes in set aside for those leaner
months to help you with this and for
those of you that want to check that
feature out you can go to
everydollar.com George we've got a
really cool promo right now two week
free trial of every dollar premium and
15 bucks off at everydollar.com George
but JC special she's gonna get it for
free hang on the line see we'll take
care of you and uh we need to get that
income up that's what I'm hearing right
now consistent income is going to help
I'll tell you what I'm hearing
you're such a giver that's what I do
it's a special website it's unbelievable
this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show thrilled
to have you with us as we talk about
your life specifically your money your
work and your relationships triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
number I'm Ken Coleman George Campbell
joins me riding shotgun today let's go
to Panama oh down to the 30A Panama City
Florida Isaac is on the line Isaac how
can we help hi Mr Coleman and Mr
Campbell thank you for thinking I've
never felt so old in my life thank you
for the respect yes thank you Isaac how
can we help
okay so I'm 18 years old I will be a
freshman in college uh this fall I've
been homeschooled all my life and my
senior year of high school I took the
foundations and personal finance course
a quick shout out to my teacher Miss Ken
vermilia who taught me nice I'm after
taking the chorus I was fully on board
with the Ramsay plan I read Financial
Peace Revisited and um so I'm all on no
credit cards not in this listening to
financial advice from broke people and
I'm living on a written budget dude you
have the wisdom of it's got all the
lines Sharp 60 year olds so I'm really
proud of you for figuring this stuff out
this early
yes sir so I'm finishing up an
internship that will pay me about forty
thousand four thousand dollars at the
end and I'll be working part-time as a
mass tutor as I go to College full-time
and um I will be attending a local state
college and living at home to cut down
on my costs and I have multiple
scholarships and my generous
grandparents have a uh 529 plan for my
siblings and I so um College will be
well taken care of wow and um so I
should be able to get through college
without debt and so
um some I have some like questions about
as I enter adulthood in the finance
world so my first question is should I
start investing in my 401k well I'm
still in college because I have so much
margin and then my second question is
when I write my budgets do I have to
include an item line for taxes
great questions okay so what are you
doing for work right now
right now it's now it's um it's an
internship at
my local navy base and we're uh we're
basically working with stem Outreach and
it's about to end actually today okay so
what's next
so next I'll be going going to college
full time and then I'll be studying for
engineering and then I will also have a
part-time math job while I'm at it
awesome so you you won't have access to
a 401k then
no I I do have access to a 401k
how is that possible if you're not
employed
I will be employed
um
but you're gonna now go be an employee
there at the Navy base
oh no I'm going to be employed at my
local College my local State College got
it okay and they have a 401k program
um no I was I'm opening up one with our
family our family's financial advisor
okay but a 401k is connected to an
employer are you talking about an IRA
um I'm not really sure
um I I know I'm just opening up an
investment or a retirement plan okay my
guess is that's going to be an
individual retirement Arrangement and
that isn't a retirement plan that is
outside of an employer that's what was
confusing me you kept saying 401K I was
like what he's the there's no employer
here okay so with the IRA you're going
to have a much lower contribution limits
but it's a great thing if you're telling
me that college is covered 100 and that
you have money some money in the bank
already
yes sir how much
um
I've got enough I'm not quite sure but
from what my grandparents told me I
could have taken an out of state school
and still been fine so okay they said
I'm well covered so if that's covered
and you have a small emergency fund
while you're in college and you're
bringing in income then you can and
should contribute to a Roth IRA that's
what I would do if I was in your shoes
and if you can Max that out every year
you know this year at 6 500 bucks you
will be crushing it and cruising later
on in life as that money grows for you
and I would invest inside of that Roth
IRA you're going to have so many
investment options so when you sit down
with your financial advisor you tell
them hey I want to do with the Ramsey
way I want to be spread across four
different types of mutual funds to
diversify and uh spread this thing out
and that will put you in a really really
great spot
and that's all the investing I would do
for now until you have a full-time job
you'll probably have access to a
different retirement plan and you'll be
Off to the Races then
now as far as taxes are you saying
you're just normal your tax returns
um yes all I know is that the government
will require taxes of me sometime and
I've just never just not sure how to do
it so I know it's different right now
because my part-time job probably won't
put me at a you know any High income or
income tax or anything yeah so here's
what you want to figure out does your
employer take out taxes my guess is that
they will unless you're like a 1099
contractor and if that's the case I
would set aside whatever money you get
just set aside 25 of that just move it
over to a savings account so that when
it comes time to do your tax return you
will have that money because you're
going to have a bill and you can also do
something called quarterly estimated
payments to the IRS if you know you're
going to have consistent side income
coming in like that
yes sir that and that you can work with
a tax Pro you can get connected at
ramseysolutions.com as well as a
smartvester pro for the financial
advising side but man what a sharp young
guy yeah he's got it together this is
what happens parents when your kids
watch the foundations in person to like
a grown adult yeah he really had its
stuff down really great he's off and
running let's go now to Emily who joins
us in Madison Wisconsin Emily how can we
help
hi I am in the process of possibly
buying my first home
um I'm 28 years old I currently make 42
000 a year I work for thriving at
Financial
um I do have some debt that I am
concerned about when it comes to being
able to afford a house and I was just
kind of wanting your guys's opinion on
that okay how much debt do you have
um including my car so my cup my auto
loan is around ten thousand eight
hundred dollars I have two credit cards
one of them with a balance of 650 the
other one's around 400.
and then I also owe on tuition which is
968 dollars
okay so let's call that what 13 Grand or
so
yes okay so how quickly can we clean up
this 13 Grand if we start selling some
stuff around the house get a side job
stop going out to eat how quickly could
we get rid of this debt
so I actually clean houses
um like airbnbs vrbo's and then
privately owned vacation homes in the
area
and we don't as a friend of mine that do
this and so we don't have an LLC and
they actually pay us in cash
we get paid once a month
through that and then I actually plan on
at the end of this month taking a decent
chunk of that and putting that towards
all of my debt good I would take all of
it and throw it at the debt that should
be your singular Focus right now do you
have any money in the bank
um I have five thousand dollars in a
savings account for
of my home and then I have around 2500
in my savings account
you got 7 500.
yep okay and then for the purchase of my
house I also have a mutual fund with
um three thousand dollars in there okay
we're at ten five for my grandparent
awesome okay well I'm gonna give you
some good news and bad news the good
news is that you have ten thousand five
hundred dollars cash which is awesome
the bad news is you keep saying this is
for the house this is for the house and
if you're following the Ramsey plan
which I'm telling you is the best path
to a peaceful Financial life and doing
this the right way that money most of
it's going to go towards the debt
baby step one thousand dollars in a
savings account everything else is going
towards that Consumer Debt but guess
what that would knock out your car loan
like today almost right if you put 9 500
towards that thing next month next month
or two that car loan's gone and now
we're down to what two grand left of
dead
yes and then once we have that done
let's get a fully funded emergency fund
on top of that thousand let's stack
three to six months of expenses
and then we can start saving up for the
house
okay now that's going to delay your
house purchase isn't it
yes and that's my that's the situation
I'm in right now is that my current
place I'm needing to be out of here by
October okay well let's go rent
somewhere else and if we need to get a
roommate let's do that
but we're not ready to just jump into a
house because our lease is ending that
is a real bad decision Emily here's what
I want you to hear when George tells you
this you don't have enough money it's
really saved up for a significant house
down payment anyway so this is going to
free up so much money in your budget to
actually reduce your expenses that's why
this is such a good move you're not
going backwards you're actually moving
forward when you use that money to pay
off this debt then now we get very
serious about the emergency fund then we
start saving for the house and it's
going to be worth the wait I promise
renting's not a sin in your situation
good hour George good stuff thank you
James Charles and the team and thank you
America for listening this is the Ramsey
Show
foreign
[Music]
do you love a good day Brandt want to
see the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show where we help you win with
your money your work and your
relationships phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
I'm Ken Coleman George Campbell joins me
this hour we are here for you taking
your money questions and your
long-term short-term work and
professional questions because that
affects your income they all go together
I'll be here to help you with those
questions and George's got you covered
on the money stuff and here we go let's
get going Chris is joining us now in
Denver Colorado Chris how can we help
hi thank you for taking my call I am
calling to ask about paying off our
house we are on baby step four five and
six and my husband just lost his job
about three weeks ago oh no sorry what
happened that is a really good question
um he was a paramedic for 28 years
and
um this came out of the blue so
um we're still trying to figure out
what's yeah if we're still trying to
figure it all out any Severance at all
um a small amount yes which one give us
what that's going to cover is that any
portion of his income
um they said it's three months um he did
a lot of overtime so it doesn't they say
three months but it's not really what he
would make in three months because he
worked a lot of overtime okay so okay
and are you working outside the home yes
I am a teacher okay and so what is the
current household income
um I make about 50 000. all right is
that enough to get you guys by well
that's my question
um
uh we will not be able to pay all of it
just on my income with our
um house payment and all the bills um
I've already paused all of our
retirement
um withdrawals and all that so um we
have
we have that small settlement and then
we also have our emergency fund but we
are in the middle of a remodel project
on our house our son is going to college
in about two weeks and our daughter is
getting married in October oh my this is
the perfect storm isn't it Chris it is
it really is it's yeah
um so I'm just trying to figure out
what's going to be the best for us to do
the remodel is about 75 done but we are
planning on cash flowing the rest of it
as well as what we have left on the
wedding my son has done awesome and he's
got scholarships and he is prepared to
hopefully pay what he will need at least
for this year
um
so my question is do we use the
emergency fund that we have and what
we're getting from the company and do we
pay off the house because we could it
would be really tight but I think we can
pay off the house and then my income
would be able to meet our bills
what's left on the mortgage I'm sorry
what's left on the mortgage about 56
000. okay and how much money do you
think you guys would have a pile of cash
once it honestly depends on we haven't
received the money from the company so
it depends on how much comes out in
taxes it's going to be very close to
um that 56 I would pause this feels like
when you're going through a storm like
this I don't like making a giant
financial decision and because we don't
know when he's going to have stable
income let's wait until he does and then
look at the pile of money we have and so
if he has his income back he's rocking
and rolling and now we have this pile of
cash we can throw at the house well is
that I have a quick question Chris and I
may have misunderstood if the 56 000 you
said would that include your emergency
fund money
now the HVAC is out and now we're extra
screwed you see where to go see where
we're going here okay yeah that
emergency fund is for an emergency now
let's be clear him losing his job feels
like an emergency yes I know I know and
and I do not want in any way to minimize
that okay because the research shows the
psychology research shows George that
losing a job has the same traumatic
impact as losing a loved one okay so I
feel bad for your husband too especially
the way you answer that question we're
not even quite sure what's going on I
didn't want to dig into that because
frankly it doesn't matter but
that emergency fund must stay in place
for emergencies he's got a little bit of
breathing room does he have three months
of breathing room you said maybe not but
he's got a couple of months he's also a
paramedic and experienced paramedic my
guess is he's got some options true or
false
uh he is he's done with the medical
field he's 28 years as a medic has taken
its toll on him okay physically
emotionally so he's done with the
medical field so he's now looking at
changing careers trying to figure out
what that looks like but let me just say
this if he if I had him on the phone I'd
go listen man this sucks the way it
happened to you I don't like it you
aren't treated with dignity and and I
understand you've been burned out you've
been doing a long time but the the worst
thing I mean excuse me the the absolute
worst thing that he can do is just sit
and look for jobs and I don't mean sit
as in he's going to be lazy or whatever
I just but this idea of just kind of
soaking in this loss and looking for a
job
he needs to go work do you understand
what I mean oh he is he's working a side
job yeah so where does that figure into
the number so give George so what's he
making because if he can even make
twenty dollars an hour 25 an hour doing
something that adds into the budget here
now we can cover all the bills
so he um he's applied for nine different
jobs he had an interview last week and
they actually offered him a position but
he leaving that he felt like God said no
that's not your job it would have been a
fourth of what he was making and he just
did not feel like that was his neck so I
I feel that but what's he doing now
what's he making so our soon to be
son-in-law has a construction business
and they just started a big project so
he is five hours from our house working
for him and I don't know we there was no
agreement on how much he was going to be
paid he felt like this is what he was
supposed to do and so he was just being
obedient and so that's what he's doing
so I don't it's not going to be
consistent and I don't know how much
that is at this point I think we need to
get that on paper because if he's making
four dollars an hour I'd rather him
going to work at Burger King down the
street it feels a little weird this is
the soon-to-be son-in-law hey Pops come
work for me we'll figure it out once you
get here I don't like that and here's
the other thing he needs to be bringing
in consistent income yes
he does he is a great provider he is on
he's all in in this stressful extremely
stressful job for 28 years so I have no
doubt that he is going to provide and do
what he needs to do I think this was a
opportunity to go do something that he
already knows his side gig has been
doing construction so even when he was
working as a paramedic he did basements
and remodels and bathrooms to me that's
the bridge that's the bridge don't sell
your house
don't empty the emergency fund
okay is that what I'm hearing George
yeah I was just saying should I pay off
the house I would not pay this off until
we have sorry yeah let's get through all
this these crazy storms with the wedding
and the college and let's figure out
what the new normal looks like then
let's look at the buckets of money we
have and go right we're ready to pay off
the house but do not clear your
emergency fund for this yeah please okay
and you're in great shape George 56 000
is doable once he gets a reset and he's
they'll pay that house off pretty quick
let's get some clarity on this income
ASAP let's figure out what he's getting
paid hourly or for the job for the
project and make sure it's worth his
time because he's too talented to be
wasting it not knowing what he's getting
paid no
I hate to hear oh you know what I want
to send him Ken Coleman's book from
paycheck to purpose as well as the get
clear assessment there it is because
he's in it he's at a Crossroads I'm not
going to call I may be a midlife crisis
I don't know it took the words right out
of my mouth so Ken's resources will help
hang on the line Chris we'll get you
from paycheck to purpose Ken's
best-selling book and his get clear
assessment love that all right quick
break then we'll be right back this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34
thousand customers who trust netsuite to
help make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com Ramsay
that's netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by George Campbell
with Ramsey personalities and we are
your hosts today triple eight eight two
five five two two five eight eight two
five five two two five let's go down to
hotlanta Atlanta Georgia Tammy's there
Tammy how can we I apologize for my
friend Ken she chuckled I heard a
chuckle that was a Pity chuckle I know a
Pity that's not a Pity chuckle that was
involuntary it made her laugh challenge
see look there's more there's more of it
she's an easy laugh how's it going Tammy
Tammy thank you for taking my call you
bet
what's up
um well I I moved to Georgia a year ago
I'm actually born and bred in California
oh okay
um I made some big decisions last year
um I apparently was following the baby
steps before I knew about the baby steps
that means you have common sense wisdom
stay clear I'm sorry that means you have
common sense wisdom yeah it's a great
sign well well maybe in part
um uh oh I feel like something else is
coming
I
almost free and clear I have zero debt I
have
uh 25
000 in my my slush fund so I have more
than enough for my three to six months
emergency fund okay I have 250 that I
put in a CD once my stepfather passed
and I put it there because
I didn't know what to do with it at the
time okay so it's it's sitting there now
um my son is a financial advisor please
don't tell him I called you all right
um he wants me to invest it I sounds
like a financial advisor to me
I have
I have I am perfectly comfortable when
it comes to real estate I've owned eight
properties
um over time
um but investing in the market scares me
to death I am actually considering
taking no more than a hundred of my 250
and I'd like to consider buying a
property in Italy reason being is that
I've got another Seven Ten Years working
life
in me
um but I would my dream is to travel and
I would love to have a home base and in
the next forever as long as I'm working
I can go there as my home base and
travel throughout Europe when I have
vacations and when I do retire I might
find myself with options
would you say are you seriously
considering living in Italy full-time
once you retire
it's it's a consideration where in Italy
I have to ask
Central Central Northern Italy tends to
be more expensive southern Italy and you
buy property in Italy for a hundred
thousand dollars
yes sir wow cash all the way or is that
a down payment
yeah I think Ken and I are now
considering I'll be honest with a
villain
sure we're talking more townhouse
in Alberto okay but that's where my mind
was going glad I brought that up that's
exactly what I was thinking I've never
heard of that place Central Italy but it
can't be that bad I bet it's lovely
isn't it
it's beautiful it's my yellow mountains
the Adriatic Sea you're in between the
both so this is a great dream so what
what is this what's whole dilemma here
yeah what's what's going on
um I've done all my have to's
um I've been divorced for 13 years I've
raised my children all of them are doing
wonderfully great
um
are you looking for permission to pay
cash for a house in Italy
I'm sorry are you looking for permission
to pay cash for a house in central Italy
I'm I I'm looking to to know if if I
should rather invest 250 000 in the
market and not have a piece set aside
for my dream that that would be a well
first of all your your dream can happen
not a bad idea I don't think there's bad
ideas I just think we need to look at
you're looking at a very black and white
and I think there's a whole lot of gray
here so here's another option what if
you take a hundred thousand you buy the
spot in Italy and you still have 150 000
and you invest that into the market
maybe in a taxable brokerage account
into index funds where you don't have to
it's not a distrust I mean that's go
it's going to appreciate over the long
term if history plays out and so that
that's what Dave Ramsey does I'll tell
you that he loves real estate more than
anyone I know he owns more real estate
more than anyone else and so if you're
second in line Dave would say hey when I
get a pile of money I park it in index
funds until I'm ready to buy more
property George tell taming what the
historical return has been on in the
stock market 10 to 12 did you hear that
Tammy
yeah but that had not been my experience
or the experiences I've known from very
close well you have not been investing
in the right things
have they been buying stocks single
stocks and playing that game or have
they been investing
my background is Mortgage Banking and so
of course we have 401k and all that for
the employees and I had one lady friend
who had to put off
um retiring for eight years when she was
ready to retire because her 401K
plummeted the last year I was working I
just quit last year I was in California
quit my job sold my house blah blah blah
and um but the whole last year that I
was working my 401k was costing me more
than I was putting in what's it doing
what's it do in the last four or five
months you've been looking at it I have
no idea because it's climb back it's
climbed all the way back you just told
me I'm going to buy this property seven
and ten years out this is a good
investment so you're a long-term thinker
but not when it comes to the stock
market that's what hurts my problem
I know but Tammy you know what fear is
based in the unknown
you just admitted to us I'm not educated
I I'm more educated in real estate than
I am certainly but what we're telling
you is George just sit down with your
son he's a financial advisor show me the
history of the stock market show me the
history of the s p 500. Tammy your 401k
climbed all the way back over the last
four or five months
in 2022 the S P 500 was down 18 can you
guess what it's doing right now in 2023
so far take a guess Tammy give us a
number
it's over 20 up
so but the thing is is what if it goes
down it's okay you're not gonna it's
fine you're not cashing out the entire
401K in one year Tammy you're going to
withdraw only what you need
so your million dollars may go down to
800 000 temporarily but you're not
withdrawing eight hundred thousand
dollars at a loss you're gonna withdraw
150 000. do you own a home right now in
the Atlanta area
yes you did say that yeah what's that
worth
about about 75 . yeah so you sell that
when you're going to Italy anyway and
you're just putting that no I
I'm well I'm not while I'm still working
the next seven ten years however long
that's amazing 10 years and what I'm
saying is when you finally check out 10
years from now if you go to Central
Italy or not you're selling a house in
Atlanta you're going to be traveling
so that's more money that's going to
continue to climb you're going to be
fine what's your nest egg today what are
you worth
375 25 and savings
50 and a CD right now
okay 650.
okay so if I'm in your shoes I'm not at
a million yet I'm not at a million yeah
that's my thing let's increase our
Network it seems very frivolous yeah
taking taking 20 of your net worth and
throwing it on an investment property
right now I would not do that you have
no retirement accounts from all those
years in banking
I do not oh so I think it's time to get
started you didn't contribute back then
because you were scared
well initially way back in the day there
it wasn't really a thing when it started
to become a thing not everybody was
involved okay it evolved into a thing
where you it's mandatory you had to yeah
I understand all right here's the deal I
think you should listen to your son that
evolved over time and then there was a
period of time I wasn't working because
I had three children and I had one child
with special needs sure so I wasn't
you're amazing yeah you're amazing
you're in great shape you have seven to
ten years to pile up retirement cash
that's what I heard George say all right
George yeah I would be piling up cash
start investing now the best time to
plant the trade was 20 years ago the
next best time is today so let's get
started don't be scared of the market
you've got a ways to go to get your nest
egg to where you can actually retire so
let's focus on that first before we jump
to this dream and you can always just
travel and just rent a hotel rent an
Airbnb you don't have to drop a hundred
thousand dollars to travel
just another option
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
show continues we're thrilled to have
you with us triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the phone number
George Campbell joins me I'm Ken Coleman
let's go to Gage who joins us now in
Salt Lake City Utah Gage how can we help
yeah so I am
in
not really in financial issues I guess
but um I just like you guys said in the
last call
um I couldn't plant the tree 20 years
ago so I'm starting today
um I have never cared about money I've
always been hey if I have one dollar
after all my bills are paid right before
I get paid again then I didn't spend
that last dollar
um I've never been money oriented that's
not part of my value system but now that
I'm engaged and I'm moving along with my
life I decided to take myself seriously
so I started looking at YouTube videos
and I found George's YouTube channel
that's brand new how about that that's
perfect oh man can I say it is pretty
funny
um I do love all the cuts that you throw
in there a little heavy sometimes but
they all hold you all right George is
taking production notes this is great
you get to hear directly from the people
thank you for that Gage I appreciate it
lighten it up a little George would you
yeah it's a it's a financial YouTube
channel not a comedy show genius I think
we need more comedy and finances don't
you guess what I'm gonna tell you right
yeah I got you to watch I mean hey they
say money can't buy happiness you know
what I mean that's true anyway how can
we help today
so um I moved back to my hometown in
Roosevelt which is just a couple hours
outside of Salt Lake and
um there's nothing to rent there is
nothing cheap to buy out here we're in a
labor boom and so there are people
flooding in the trailer parks are full
the RV campsites outside of town are
full with people living here in their
campers
um basically my only two options to get
into a home are I for one I stay with my
mother and her husband for the next 18
months or so until I can get the rest of
my down payment for my new home
construction done or I buy myself a
camper and go into debt right now and
um do the same thing everyone else is
doing to have my own space with me and
my fiance everyone is on the road Gage I
don't know if you've looked around man
but I'm not going to do what everyone
else is doing so I don't like either of
these options right now what's your
income agreed uh around 100 I work it's
basically a day rate I get paid by the
load but it's usually five to six
hundred dollars a day awesome good
income okay and how much do you have
saved
um I've only got a thousand I was paying
all my bills quadruple payments and um I
had 10 grand in savings and after I
watched your YouTube channel it led me
to the baby steps and so I dumped 9000
in my debt I've got about 18 000 left in
um debt Consumer Debt cars and Tool
trucks I used to be a mechanic so they
are not cheap but can you sell any of
that stuff
um not
really I mean I could but those
they're so expensive that they'd
appreciate extra
extraordinarily fast so I'd be getting
literally Pennies on the dollar you said
you used to be a mechanic so are you
using the tool truck still
uh no no I'm not adding any more tools
to my collection and they're almost paid
off
okay I just I wouldn't keep it around if
you're not using it I'd still sell it
even if you're not going to make it I
don't I I have all the equipment to work
on my own vehicles and I do
um so every time I need an oil change
tire rotation uh swapping out tires on
um our semis and stuff like that at work
so I do use them and they make my life
and my job easier
okay I I mean yeah I I could sell them
but I've got 20 000 into it I get four
maybe well here's the deal you've got
debt and Home Ownership is not on the
current Horizon we've got to clean up
this debt and pay off the 18K get a
fully funded emergency fund then begin
saving up the down payment
so that is the plan I don't like the
idea of you I mean how old are you
uh 27. okay so you're still young you
got plenty of time if you did move back
in with mom and her husband for a little
while I would have real strict
parameters on it and I have a real
strict savings goal saying hey I'm gonna
clean up this debt and walk away with
ten thousand bucks in the bank with my
emergency fund then I'm gonna go rent
somewhere even if I have to get four
roommates
now if I'm your in your shoes I might
just go get a bunch of Roommates now
right and make something work well
isn't really uh Financial there it's
availability
um I have can you move only seeing
that's the problem is that I I can't
find anywhere you can't move anywhere in
the country I just don't believe that
okay so sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
the job I'm at
is
um very
I don't know how to say this it takes no
skill but I also have no skill so I'm a
truck driver in the oil field
um you have to know somebody to get
these kind of high paying like I could
go anywhere from the next town over you
can't continue this job
um not
not not why so I've checked so Duchesne
is about 45 or 30 miles away and vernal
is the next nearest town which is about
another 35-40 miles away I constantly
have been looking in there
um and I have not found any like okay so
I found one one bedroom apartment for
1500 bucks a month
okay was ridiculous like it's just the
environment here man Gage dude I'm on
team gauge I'm trying to root for you
you're not rooting for yourself at every
single turn over the six minutes you've
had excuses and why you can't and how
this is the only option and the longer
you live like that the longer you're
gonna stay broke you just said okay that
you didn't have any skills that's just
simply not true oh so I didn't mean that
like I don't have any skills like I'm
licensed to hell I have my class a
um
I've got a ton of stuff I just I'm
wondering
so what are my options then what what is
there because I've looked into the
roommates I'm not idly sitting by in my
mother's house taking advantage of her
get a two bedroom with a roommate that
brings your rent down to probably a
thousand bucks a month
but there was a two-bedroom available
you're telling me in the next month
there's going to be zero rentals
available across your entire 40 mile
radius I just don't buy that
I'm telling you in the last three months
I have not seen anything
I think you're not looking hard Maybe
I just don't buy it what's the big
challenge I feel like we're what's the
big problem you want to solve what is it
so I like I said I've been paying off my
debt like crazy
um by January I should be debt free and
saving up
and I'm so I'm currently living with my
mother right now and I'm wondering
should I get this camper and live out do
not have the camper no I'd rather you
stay with your mom I'd rather stay with
your mom and get out of debt follow our
baby steps stop trying to make this more
complicated that I know but I'm trying
to encourage you with a little bit of
like hey No Nonsense I don't care if you
stay with your mom for a while that's
fine but you either go get a roommate
stop making excuses to why you can't
find a place to rent but if you want to
stay with your mom for a while as long
as you're being intentional and getting
out of debt and walking our baby steps
out then I'm fine with that but that's a
short-term solution because you need to
fly and I I think there's something over
him you know you make a hundred thousand
dollars you can afford 1500 bucks in
rent yes you can it's fine but I'm not
going to argue with him on that it's
like okay yeah if he can to say that
there's no place to rent and you can
find a trucking jobs all over the
country so you're not stuck that's the
problem you're not gonna feel like I'm
stuck there's no options I gotta go into
debt and that's only going to compound
the problem right now it's time to fly
you know and I I think getting out of
debt will give you a little bit more
confidence I see I feel a blanket of
self-doubt that's hanging on this guy
and I hate that for you Gage I want to
help you a little bit hang on the line
I'm going to give you two resources one
the get clear career assessment I think
it's going to give you a level of
self-awareness you've never had before
and I'm gonna give you my book from
paycheck to purpose which is like the
field guide that'll lead you up the
mountain that you want to climb
professionally and then get clear
assessment will help you to identify
that mountain but man stop making
excuses
and move forward this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by George camel
thrilled that you are with us our
scripture of the day comes from
Ecclesiastes 3 11. he has made
everything beautiful in its time he has
also set eternity in the human heart yet
no one can fathom what God has done from
beginning to end
and from Ecclesiastes to Adam Sandler
because why not our quote of the day
you've just got to give yourself time
that's good advice I think give yourself
time to figure out what you're good at
and what you're not good at can you do
that in the voice do you have an Adam
Sandler voice I would offend all people
groups if I even attempted it's a tough
one to do well you got to get a little
nasally you got to get up high in the
throat that's where you start you know
it's like so uh you've just got to give
yourself time electrical device oh
that's actually pretty good yeah I like
that I mean that was without any
rehearsal so I'm very nervous doing that
thank you George the best part of that
quote is the fact that in as soon as he
started it he reflected and said I think
that's good advice yeah because he's so
real yeah and now I can definitely
neuroticism him and I share that yes oh
he's hilarious let's go to Anna in
Birmingham Alabama Anna how can we help
hey guys thanks for having me you bet
what's up
um so we are on baby steps four five and
six and we are looking forward to
upgrading our home
um to expand our family a little bit
more in the future and want to make sure
we make the best choices to not
um set us back in some of our other
goals in the future okay give us some of
the details
all right so we bought our current house
in 2021 amazing interest rate 2.5
um wow and we have yeah just really
looked out on that one we don't have any
other debt it's just the mortgage now
um and we still owe close to 150 000 on
it
um and we are looking forward to buying
another house in the next three to five
years and really I don't know you know
is it worth acting like we're back in
Step 3B and just piling into our equity
and like pausing retirement pausing 529
or do we just Chuck along with what
we've got going on now why would you
pause retirement
to pay the house off a little bit faster
and get more equity in there
um I wouldn't pause retirement there's
no point unless you had some kind of
emergency storm where you would ever
pause retirement in baby steps four
through six so I would continue just
paying down the mortgage as much as you
can once the retirement set you've got a
little going to the 529 plan for the
kids then put whatever's left towards
the principal on the mortgage
okay and you said this is three to five
years from now what's your income right
is that household income yes okay
so this is going to be tougher to pay
down the mortgage and upgrade to the new
one what's the new one going to cost
that's what we don't know we're kind of
using you know as much as we can put
equity in this would help us make the
decision on that okay and what's your
current house worth
it is worth now 235 we bought it for 165
interesting how much did you put down
um like nine thousand dollars we had
like the lowest yeah the lower is this a
30 year
yes it is okay uh I would just continue
paying the house down normally do not
pause retirement because you have the uh
opportunity to retire broke if you pause
it now to try to pay down this house and
I want this money to compound for you
guys and so there's a balance here
there's a delicate dance in baby steps
four through six and you don't want to
put all those eggs into one thing so
first comes retirement then College then
we'll pay down the house and um you know
this is something that was I don't know
George what you think about this this
was a mental hack that I that I came up
with early on when I first bought a home
I started looking at the amortization
schedule
oh do you they fire me up yeah so do you
look at yours
yes we have all right so and I'll put
like outrageous little numbers in there
to see like how can I pay it off in one
year well but but again instead of just
so keep keep pouring into retirement
okay right but by looking at that
schedule and going all right if we were
to put in just one you start with one
extra mortgage payment a year what would
that do over the next three to five
years you we're working with the game
plan you just gave us okay and then if
you go okay if I do what if I put in the
equivalent of three or five and just see
how that because I just think you're
gonna get more Equity over the next
three to five years and you realize just
by putting in a little extra where you
can But continuing on retirement does
that make sense sure yeah well I wanted
to see that she's still making Headway
the biggest piece of this equation as I
look at it is increasing your income
without question that helps you guys if
your joint income sixty three thousand
yeah so I stay home um and homeschool
the kids but I'm also like I work
part-time but it's I mean like seven
thousand what does he do
he works for a church wow well see
that's that's limited I mean it's just
not like the corporate ladder so you
know side jobs you know uh things of
that nature maybe a side hustle business
that you guys can get up and running
maybe that generates 25 30 000 a year
you know those are the kinds of things
you can do but right now trying to
upgrade in-house is not not a good idea
and definitely don't pause retirement
George is right you want to keep that
momentum going so this might not be a
three to five year Journey you might
need to upgrade later on you might need
to make a more lateral move you might
need to make do with the space you have
but right now the income is what's
limiting you guys yeah well thank you
for the call let's go to Sally now who
joins us in Austin Texas Sally how can
we help
um so my question is
I'm currently on baby step number two
but I have already started five
completed six and have an emergency fund
basically what I need help with is
I have money in those accounts to pay
off all debts
would that be a smart move or would it
be better to just start with the
snowball method now
with where I'm at by accounts what do
you mean lay out what's in the accounts
and where they're at
so my kids college funds both of them
already have fifty thousand dollars in
each account
home is paid off and in our emergency
fund we have forty thousand dollars
our total debts only equal 124 000
dollars
what are those debts so I have
those debts are a truck payment and a
construction loan what's the truck
payment what's left on that
on the truck
yes what is this truck for does it come
with a refrigerator and a microwave
an impulsive
um I hope so but I mean we don't we
don't struggle to pay it it's not an
issue but what's your household income
you could get rid of
a household income is 180 000. okay
fantastic income uh what could you sell
the truck for and what's left on the
loan
um the loan is 47
000. and it is worth more
um I think we have an equity of ten
okay I here's a plan you I don't know
that you're going to do it but if you
sold that truck it would leave you with
77 000 or so on the construction loan
correct and then you could take the
majority of that emergency fund because
right now you're in debt so you're in
baby step two which means we have a
thousand dollar emergency fund that
would then cut your construction loan
about in half
and now making 180 how quickly can we
pay off the remaining you know 30 grand
35 Grand
probably four or five months
correct boom
So the plan I just laid out you are
completely debt free and you'll be back
to having a fully funded emergency fund
with probably within I'd say eight
months at this rate
right I I guess I mean
essentially I mean I could be out of
debt tomorrow but do well that's saying
you're going to cash out your What do
you do not take out a HELOC do not cash
out these college plans don't touch
anything right that that was where that
was where my question was no is it
dumped to hold on to the money that I've
already saved it's done to withdraw it
with all of the penalties that you're
going to pay
correct that is going to be a giant
stoop attack so it is not wise to do
that use any liquid cash that has no
penalty which right now is only your
emergency fund
that's the advice take it or leave it
it's what I would do it's what Ken
Coleman would do we want to see you debt
free with a peaceful life that's it
that's our tested interest that's all we
needed was a little butter Bing
there it is that's what we all come here
for folks George Campbell great hour
thank you sir always enjoy to be with
you in studio to our fearless leader
James Childs thank you and the team
behind the glass and you America thank
you to wonderful folks in the lobby you
all are amazing this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's George camel if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsaysolutions.com and click get
started foreign
[Music]